a source tells ET that Matt Lauer is
still hoping for a comeback the former
Today Show host is living a private life
in the Hamptons in New York after he was
abruptly fired last November from the
morning show due to alleged
inappropriate sexual behavior in the
workplace one source tells ET that
Lauer's days are lonely now adding Matt
definitely regrets his behavior he lost
not only his family but his career and
many of his closest friends the Today
Show was his life as for the 60 year
olds relationship with his wife Annette
Roke the source says the two aren't
headed towards a reconciliation and were
having marriage issues even before the
scandal broke quote their marriage is
completely over the last two years of
their marriage were hell a net had to
hear about Matt's wandering eye
incessantly but when it comes to his
career a second source tells ET that
Lauer is hoping to make a return he has
seen a lot of people comeback and hopes
he will too
his team has discussed a public apology
but agreed disappearing right now seems
to be for the best
[Applause]
you